cancer is the second leading cause of
death in the United States but if cancer
is detected in its early stages chances
of survival are much greater here to
talk about the importance of screening
is Dr apeksha Desai of Ace Primary Care
a contracted provider for Optimum Care
Network Nevada sponsors of this segment
doctor thank you so much for being here
today thank you thank you so much for
having me so you're right cancer is
responsible for almost 20 percent of all
deaths in the United States however a
lot of those debts are preventable with
screening tests when done early to
detect those cancers early before
they've had a chance to develop symptoms
grow or spread what type of cancers does
a screening intercept
mended by United States preventive
Services Task Force so how often and how
many screenings should one person get so
it depends on your
s and your age
but almost always
everybody would benefit from having
screenings done for these kinds of
cancers so mammograms are the best
screening test for breast cancer and
most women will benefit from starting
around age 40. their uh frequency Can
Depend based on their individual risk
profile but when detected early it's
much easier to treat and cure breast
cancer for colorectal cancer now the
recommendations are to start screening
at age 45. colon cancer mostly develops
in pre-cancerous polyps and when
detected early they can be removed
before they become cancerous are the
home tests that I've seen advertised are
those effective or is it better to go
ahead and get the full screen no
actually the home test so some of the
homes tool test like you may have heard
of cologuard and such those tests can be
pretty good for the right candidate so
if you have history of polyps
then those are not good tests so for
certain candidates it's um it's a good
test also if you've never had a
colonoscopy it's a good idea to have at
least one yeah and how can doctors help
well first of all we want to make sure
that patients feel comfortable talking
to their doctors about screening if you
don't see a doctor or haven't been to a
doctor in a long time make sure you go
to your doctor and bring up screening so
they can advise you regarding tests that
are appropriate for your age and risk
factor profile and and get you going
with those tests and if your doctor
recommends a test that you're not
comfortable with doing for whatever
reason speak up say so and then they
might be able to offer you various
options and Alternatives like we
discussed that there are more options
now say for colonoscopy and others so
the most important thing though is make
sure you talk to your doctor and don't
hesitate to bring up your concerns and
and they can work through it well Dr
Desai this is life-saving information we
appreciate you being here very much you
would want to thank Optum Care Network
Nevada for sponsoring this segment you
can call them at that number on your
screen or visit
optimcare.com Nevada for more
information we'll be back
[Music]